life on our planet originated in water
this assumption forms the basis of the
biogenesis theory today
and is practically beyond any doubt in
the scientific community
it is water in its liquid state that
offers the best conditions for life to
originate
and evolve in however if we were to cast
our gaze around
we would see various organisms not only
in oceans and rivers
but also on the planet's surface in the
soil
in the lower strata of the atmosphere
and even in the mouths of volcanoes
when and why did life break away from
the hospitable ocean
and move on to exploring forbidding
barren land
let's try to get to the bottom of it
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
up until the late proterozoic eon all
life on the earth was to be found
only in oceans throughout that
prehistoric period
land on the surface of the planet would
alternately be covered first by giant
ice caps
then by barren lifeless expanses similar
to martian landscapes
and back again ediacaran the last period
in the proterozoic started approximately
635 million years ago
and persisted for 94 million years
the earth of the time was far from being
the most hospitable place
if today's human were to experience the
environment of that period
he or she would very soon pass out due
to asphyxiation
as oxygen concentration in the air was
twice as low back then as it is now
landscapes of the diachron period were
endless deserts and rocky mountains
devoid of any signs of life meanwhile
the coastal area of the ocean was
crawling with highly unusual creatures
not even remotely resembling any of
today
they were mainly soft-bodied and
non-motile
that is they couldn't move around and
fed of nutritious particles in water
these organisms supposedly didn't have
either muscles
or a developed nervous system or a hard
carapace
with practically no predators around all
these things were by the long and the
short of it
not yet called for predators
emerged at the very end of the ediacaran
period at once establishing their
dominance in the prehistoric ocean
active hunting proved to be a highly
effective survival strategy
as the soft-bodied non-motile dwellers
of the ocean's bottom
unable to either escape from the enemy
or put up a decent fight or even hide
were easy prey in a way
the ocean was an endless smorgasbord for
first predators
full of nutritious food right there for
the taking
it is hardly surprising that most
prehistoric creatures making up the menu
didn't last long others had to adapt
to deal with the new dangers
[Music]
approximately 542 million years ago
there began a period that was to greatly
contribute to changing what our planet
was like
geological layers of that time are
filled with fossils that used to be
highly organized living creatures these
finds give grounds to suppose that the
prehistoric ocean used to be teeming
with creatures
sporting an impressive outer skeleton or
carapace
referred to as the cambrian explosion
the process
heralded a new breakthrough in the
history of evolution of life on our
planet
and the beginning of the phanerozoic eon
or the eon of visible life
the first period of the phanerozoic eon
is called
cambrian it started 542 million years
ago
and continued for about 56 million years
trilobites are the most well-known and
widespread creatures of the time
although these creepy things are not the
only ones the cambrian is notable for
this was the period when the prey
predator system was finally established
it goes without saying that in the
millions of years that followed
natural conditions would interfere with
the established food chains
with some species dying out and others
riding high
but the principle stayed predation
became a potent incentive for evolution
which forced organisms to change in
order to be able to deal with new
threats
as well as to explore new areas so far
inaccessible to predators
[Music]
the cambrian explosion produced a great
many completely new forms of
organization of living organisms
many of them didn't prove to be viable
and eventually vanished off the face of
the earth
others on the other hand brought about a
great diversity of new species
for example approximately 550 530
million years ago
tiny bottom dwellers resembling mollusks
known as haikulis
developed a sturdy notochord going
through the entire body
these creatures are believed to be some
of the most ancient ancestors of today's
vertebrates
picayas came a bit later these were not
very large creatures either
they looked like lancelets flatworms or
primitive fish
proud owners of a sturdy and flexible
cord with muscles attached to it
they were able to swim by wriggling
their entire body
in a series of s-shaped movements this
manner of swimming proved to be quite
effective and fast
which allowed early chordates to survive
and evolve into higher organized species
admittedly almost all paleontological
finds dating back to the cambrian are
those of marine dwellers
as the overwhelming majority of the
living organisms of that period
lived in the ocean some of these
creatures we can see in fossil finds
look highly peculiar and even horrifying
a normal car
is for example was a giant shrimp
measuring up to 60 centimeters in length
it was also one of the apex predators in
the cambrian period
and even though other fines appear
rather bleak in comparison
they are proof of some really important
phenomena
among these the most ancient fossil
finds of land soils can be mentioned
they date back to around 530 million
years ago
which corresponds to the middle and late
cambrian
without any specific knowledge in the
field one will fail to see anything
special
in these ordinary looking stones however
these prints show that it was around
this time that first primitive algae and
microorganisms
started to venture onto land
later having thrived in their lifetime
they died
and decomposed thus forming a nutritious
substrate for their descendants
first colonies of microorganisms must
have formed in humid and warm places on
land
in shallow waters for example or in the
tidal zone of the ocean
with plenty of water and light and with
no animals around that would be keen on
eating them
young algae flourished successfully
adapting to the new conditions
single cell algae was soon joined by
primitive fungi
which were not able to synthesize
nutrients on their own
but could feed on what remained of dead
weeds
a hundred million years later the
symbiosis of fungi and single cell algae
produced lichens these undemanding
things were to become tip of the spear
in exploring great expanses of new
territories
the ordovician period which followed the
cambrian
began approximately 485 million years
ago
and continued for around 42 million
years
this is when marine life was actively
evolving
in the ocean mollusks and arthropods
were thriving
among the latter's euryptorids many of
which dwelt to the bottom
to get around more conveniently these
creatures
used their jointed limbs this feature
would later be an indispensable acid
and an important factor in adaptation to
life on land
apart from these there evolved jawless
animals similar to today's lampreys
and a bit later their emerged cartilage
fish
meanwhile plants slowly but surely
made their way inland and away from
water
first multicellular plants emerged which
were clearly able to survive on land
they left imprints of spores and vessels
that delivered water to the upper parts
of the plants
animals on the other hand still didn't
venture out of their regular environment
although it is probable that some
crustaceans did have a chance to explore
coastal areas
this period ended in the ordovician
silurian extinction event
its causes are still not clearly defined
yet
but according to the most popular theory
it was brought about by global ice age
and a fall in the level of the global
ocean that followed
be it as it may up to 50 percent of all
the species vanished off the face of the
earth as a result of the extinction
however life was able to adapt to new
conditions
and even take it to a completely new
level
next in line was the silurian period
which continued from 444
to 419 million years ago
this was when giant arthropods dominated
the ocean
and it is then that one might come
across a euriptarid measuring up to two
and a half meters in length
fishes also thrived among which large
and swift predators over one meter long
come to think of it it is hardly
surprising that some living creatures
preferred to leave the ocean and try to
find other
safer areas for their habitats and so
this is when first arthropods
came on shore these were prehistoric
europeans and other crustaceans
their tough chitinous carapace protected
them from exposure to the sun and drying
as well as kept their body in shape
their small legs allowed them to move
around
on hard surfaces when out of water it is
reasonable to suppose that first
arthropods that ventured on land
made a point of not getting too far from
water
their respiratory organs had to remain
moist in order to function correctly
however the arthropods were greatly
tempted by the abundance of plant food
that was there for the taking just
beside the sea
the safety factor guaranteed by land was
another attraction
as predators hadn't yet learned to chase
their prey
if the latter escaped to land gradually
these explorers fully adapted to the new
conditions
and came onto land for good which later
made for an incredible diversity of
species among insects and spiders
as well as other classes of living
creatures
approximately 419 million years ago
the devonian period began which was the
most important one in terms of land
exploration
it lasted for around 60 million years
this is when rhinophytes spread all over
the planet
prehistoric vascular plants and
ancestors of acquisitasia
mosses and ferns reaching three meters
in height
they densely covered all humid and warm
places of the planet
mainly coastal areas of seas and the
deltas of rivers flowing into them
however neither rhinophytes nor mosses
and lichens that emerged later
had a proper root system instead of a
network of roots
that would keep a plant firmly in place
they adjust
primitive root stocks at best that is
why
soils would quickly get washed into
rivers and turn them into muddy streams
and their deltas into swamps
in these humid places rich in organic
matter plants were flourishing
giving food to insects and other
inhabitants of the earth of that time
fish in their turn were attracted to
marshy areas by the abundance of insects
and their larvae eventually great
amounts of putrefying organic matter
absorbed oxygen from the water in swamps
which affected the breathing of the
creatures living there
that is why to compensate for the lack
of oxygen fish in those waters
learned to take gulps of atmospheric air
gradually they developed a breathing sac
allowing them to survive
outside their aquatic habitat
simultaneously other appendages were
developing
thick stalks and trunks of plants
growing in marshes
offered to fish reliable shelter from
larger predators
however it was hard for them to make
their way through these thickets
thin fins were not adequate for the
purpose more powerful and muscular limbs
were called for
that is how the fins of fish dwelling in
marshy environments grew longer
and developed additional bones that
strong muscles were attached to
these were first lung fish and in
particular psychopterygie
eustinopteran is a typical
representative of these
even though this strong finned fish
wasn't keen on settling on land
it was already able to breathe
atmospheric air and stay out of water
for certain periods
shallow swamps would often dry out which
is why their inhabitants would have to
migrate to other
more humid places favorable for life and
to do this
they naturally had to move across
stretches of land
this is the way acanthus steger got
about it for example
which lived around 365 million years ago
in the late devonian
one of the first known creatures
intermediate between fish and amphibians
acanthus stega had gills scales and a
tail fin
just like any other fish at the same
time
this fascinating creature sported four
legs and a breathing sack like that of
amphibians
that allowed it to breathe atmospheric
air unfortunately
acanthus stega's limbs were not strong
enough to support its weight
and its thorax muscles couldn't pump
oxygen for too long
that is why it stayed mostly in water
sometimes crawling from one body of
water to take a dunk in another
gradually the ability of prehistoric
sarcopteryji to breathe atmospheric air
improved their fins grew in power and
turned into fully fledged pores
their appearance underwent great changes
for example tiktaalik a prehistoric
sarcopterygian amphibian fish
that lived at around the same time as a
kantha steger
had a flat head like that of a frog
being anatomically intermediate between
fish and amphibians tiktaalik had
powerful fins
that were able to prop up its body and
move it across solid surfaces
in addition this amphibian fish could
breathe with both its gills
and its lungs the way its ossicle is
designed
is proof of tiktaalik's ability to
easily distinguish sounds
both on land and in water all these
signs
show that this creature spent as much
time out of water as in it
in the carboniferous period which
followed the devonian
amphibians came onto land for good
settling in all sorts of ecological
niches
in their revolutionary struggle they
developed into such animal classes as
reptiles and synapsids
a great diversity of conditions outside
the ocean
stimulated and spurred the evolutionary
process on
as land dwellers are exposed to a much
wider range of temperatures and other
factors
than water dwellers incidentally this
question may arise
why did animals come onto land only once
in the entire history of evolution
why didn't a single marine species
venture to live on land
in the past 350 million years
the answer isn't as elaborate as it
might seem
[Music]
marine creatures are adapted to living
in an aquatic habitat
the overwhelming majority of them are
useless and actually helpless when out
of water
to live in another environment they
would need a whole other skeleton
structure
as well as outer skin or fur or shell
for that matter
and organs of breathing vision and
hearing
the proverbial fish out of water is even
more helpless than a human in the open
sea
it is a foregone conclusion that
stranded fish is there for the taking
for any land creature
that would care to have it when coming
onto land in the paleozoic period
plants arthropods and vertebrates went
on to occupy
vacant ecological niches they didn't
have
natural enemies in the new environment
while there was plenty of food around
the chief negative factor in the new
environment was not
other creatures but other conditions
fortunately
the species were able to take their time
adapting to them
interestingly an example of the other
way around is known to us
prehistoric ancestors of cetacea went
back to living in an aquatic environment
at the same time dominating certain
ecological niches
strange though it may seem on the face
of it there is actually nothing
controversial about it
the fact is that things to adapt to in
the terrestrial environment
are tougher and more diverse that is why
getting back in the water could be a
smart move
in order to survive whales dolphins and
other secondary aquatic inhabitants of
oceans
seas and rivers are living evidence
confirming the fact that evolution
is not irreversible if in certain
circumstances
it is better to take a step back that's
what it will do
exploring land produced millions of new
living creatures
one of which was the human incidentally
a similar process is taking place right
now terrestrial life
is making attempts to explore a new
environment
harsh demanding and endlessly attractive
it is space and mankind's dream is to
break away from the earth
the environment we're confined to and
move on to populating other worlds as
wonderful as our planet
when working on every new video we
evolve too
and do our utmost to make it better than
the previous one
do share the link with your friends and
let's dream together
please hit the like button and this way
we will know that you enjoyed the fruits
of our labor let's keep in touch
[Music]
you